[Music]
and creepy robot news submitted by
Moscow Moscow Mule yeah yeah George
Jetson
Russia Russia Moscow mules so you can
buy a robot clone of anybody from this
Russian startup I mean Morgan Freeman
that's I'm getting Josh oh say we don't
you this money what do you mean by robot
clone okay a Russian startup is selling
autonomous robots which buyers can
choose to make look like any person on
earths it moves and everything yeah how
much everyone will be able to order a
robot for any appearance for
professional or personal use thus
there's a huge market and service
education and entertainment imagine a
replica of Michael Jordan selling
basketball uniforms tainment and William
Shakespeare reading his own text in a
museum and that's the that's the
director of promo do they actually walk
in with right till I show you a picture
of this I caught the first word you said
was service yeah not educational but
service that's right that's right
written down here they already know so
basically it's just a torso it's just a
neck and a torso but it cannot walk so I
can't walk around at least caffeine
moving parts allowing it to make 600
micro-expressions and artificial
intelligence containing 100,000 speech
modules so far this is sounding creepy
yeah putting on this on this thing I
just want my self what yourself no he
said Maureen Freeman Morgan Freeman yeah
Morgan Freeman I don't know I just want
to see it attach the boss dynamic pick
somebody Oh Josh Josh okay why you
[ __ ] know one okay well I already
seen this pictures oh no all right so
imagine this company making that person
the shoe on it on this robot pretty
rough
yeah but then like think about it you
guys you guys don't you have to turn on
the computer for JK news it would just
be a riot or so giving JK news all the
time whenever you
just like dude that'd be great and be
like an alarm system but you place it in
front of your front door they ring the
doorbell yeah I guess this company wants
to have these so that you can break down
the human machine like barrier that's
been so elusive to crack but I'm like
bro no one's [ __ ] breaking down that
barrier with that [ __ ] face do but
the [ __ ] eyes that look like they're
popping out of your skull the craziest
things that that's only a 3d rendering
right uh like I don't
well then maybe that one physical can't
even make it look a little bit nicer
dude you're not even printing anything
yet that almost looks real that was all
right I get it so far looks real it's
just cuz you're blind my god why do you
do game that looks that looks pretty
real no that's that's failure in there
no okay well yeah so yeah so they want
that
I guess imagine like it's they I guess
they want it for like like store
displays and stuff like that and like
bank tellers and something that I could
get if I start is blaze it just feels
like it's out creepy because you ready
got mannequins there yeah but like them
it I don't like it when the mannequins
have faces no you know an Old Navy how
they have the [ __ ] like a cartoony
face I feel the whole family there you
can like dogs creepy so then what would
you rather have on it for a face to not
be creeped out by it I would just rather
have like a smooth like kind of like the
robotic pixelated face or something this
is already just like a lot though it's
not even a fool no no like just like a
mannequin with like but he's a pixel
like you know like a I bow faces like
I've died though the only world
oh it's like it's like that screen and
it's just like yeah just like animoso
dots and then like a smile is just a
head in the torso right yeah don't they
already have that one the one that can
like talk and everything and move its
face yeah I mean this one can do that
but like kind of that's what this one
can do yeah so like like like what I
know I [ __ ] hate this I [ __ ] hate
this solely because it reminds me of a
doll that's living and I don't want a
dog I [ __ ] hate all [ __ ] humanoid
and that can like that is like something
that was in a van in animate that
becomes adamant yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] dude
I don't want them coming after me I'm
just joking I don't know what happened
to me again what do you got even with
the I dog hi dogs you know what you can
poke its nose and like there's a little
backflip sometimes so hate it dogs are
fine but it's like human little toy
people with I don't get mad at you and
gets like red eyes I don't know animals
is like a different Association but like
the Furby o'connell Barbies are freaking
out dude ideas go there either [ __ ]
huge I think they had like a glitch or
something with them right where they
would turn on and my new [ __ ] oh my god
man and that [ __ ] happen to us it was
like come out of the closet to each
other that [ __ ] freaked me out because
my friends had for a reason they kept it
in closet and at night you hear them
talking to you
piece of [ __ ] no it doesn't matter if
they have an on/off switch they turn on
that's what's scary because they scared
the [ __ ] out of it you see the thing
that scares me is this that like here's
the thing right so if they can talk to
each other cool but the fact that what
if they aren't really talking to each
other but then they feel like
something's there in front of them so
that means there's a spirit there Oh for
me when I was growing up we thought that
it was like possessed yeah so like it's
not talking to girls it is so it's
moving on a Ouija board
YouTube channel that like melts like
toys or whatever and they've like set
fired like a Furby and you see like the
skeleton because it's just like this
like battery mound and like two eyes and
a mouth is like you know Pat as he was
watching it he's just going what is that
movie that looks like Furbys is a
gremlin gremlin yeah cuz they remind you
for a reason yeah yeah yeah yeah and
they're eating vegetables
that's troll 2 you're eating or didn't
show in the Philippines yeah we're both
of you are from Nelson's Vietnamese
we're running Norfolk there's a running
joke that your food backpack
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't had an open though now for
reference do you want to explain what a
backpack is it's a vagina
oh yeah DS Oh poo Nani is vagina - yeah
[Music]
what why did you whisper that no I'm
gonna pick that up now I'm like I think
he's thinking to himself yeah I know I
mean have you guys seen the like robots
that like come off as like rip waiters
and stuff like that and watch at
restaurants that are just like they've
got the screen on them and you like sign
in with that many check I have it might
be down cuz there's a couple at the mall
that actually have that and it's which
mall same you know Santa Anita mall yeah
they have humans or is it are you
talking about the Camaro no no no not
the cardboard cutout it's like a like a
big robot that's like a smooth robot
it's not very human-like it doesn't have
human features on the Jetsons kind of
like made like smooth but it's um you
like go up to it it's got like an iPad
on its chest and you like punch in your
like number and I go to random humans
like they're thinking like oh is this
the robot you start poking the chair
just like I want to sign in for five
people oh five sir stop poking me yeah
is like he's like no take my order yeah
I mean they got the robot bartender in
downtown that's a big arm right yeah
it's in like you can go to a normal
bartender or you can order at the robot
one yeah and just not [ __ ] tip that
[ __ ] but you do the roll I think
doesn't work those like McDonald's
Springs those never work
food like screens we can order I don't
want to talk to people yeah sometimes
it'll be really awkward though because
I'll walk in and I'll see that like
somewhat like a cashier is like standing
at the register or whatever
I don't like makes eye contact they
probably don't to talk to you - so I
feel bad because like if it were me like
working like retail or something that I
would like standing there and I'm
probably bored out of my [ __ ] I just
want to like do something and then this
guy comes in please it's my chance and
then like they're just like I'd rather
talk to this screen self-checkout starts
going on crusty stories and people are
like what is [ __ ] what have to do
this myself and everyone's confused I I
do I go for that every time because you
know [ __ ] worse is when the [ __ ]
people don't know how to use it yeah and
then a that called someone over my going
white if you need someone to come over
and do it for you dude you know what I
hate about normal check out what people
comment and the things you're buying
like what are you making tonight oh yeah
talk to you sometimes I bought like I
bought like really weird causes of
things or it's just like I think I'd
like a 12-pack of beer and then like
[ __ ] it I don't know some really really
see out really specific like ingredient
and they're just like that kind of night
huh I was this guy's cool how much the
robots were oh no I don't think so I
mean I imagine they says that however
the Android watch promo bot calls a
completely anthropomorphic machine only
has eight hours of battery life it's
just like really weird like why maybe
keeping it ethical only work eight hours
well think about are you really taking
workplaces where you're not keeping
plugged in because it doesn't even have
[ __ ] legs yeah that's so you'd be
like all right come to take my doll with
me and carry it around with you
throughout the day no matter what yeah
can you imagine like and like underneath
your arm be like oh man so I know we got
a battery bank my robots gonna do
imagine my brother things you asked here
you're like hey robot
what time is it do you have it before
killing your own it's just like
[Laughter]
[Music]
you